so sieht's aus jetzt bin ich wirklich
mal gespannt ob das bei mir auch klappt
an sich geht es halt einfach darum diese
hört jetzt ziemlich brutaler ist es auch
eigentlich echt was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe es natürlich euch bis
gut wie ihr sehen könnt es geht heute
wie in letzter zeit fast immer um essen
ich habe letztens einen kommentar
gelesen ob ich jetzt eigentlich nur noch
so essens videos mache dazu kann ich
sagen natürlich nicht nur also bald
wieder andere sachen allerdings macht am
meisten spaß deswegen ich weiß nicht ich
will eigentlich immer das machen was mir
am meisten spaß macht und ich hoffe dass
es auch okay für alle leute die auch
gerne andere videos von mir sind aber
das kommt bald auf jeden fall wieder auf
jeden fall muss ich am anfang direkt mal
sagen ich habe mich für dieses video so
ein bisschen inspirieren lassen also ich
habe die ideen dazu schon öfter mal im
netz gesehen auf instagram so leischik
mäßig aber auf youtube und ich dachte
mir ich finde das eigentlich cool wir
probieren es einfach mal aus und mal
schauen ob es klappt es geht nämlich auf
der einen seite so um sich mal und auf
der anderen seite kann man dann auch
sagen das sind halt alles ihr seht ja
früchte die wir auch eine ganz bestimmte
art und weise essen und wenn man sich
dann diese hacks anschaut denkt man sich
ok jeder ist zum beispiel so eine art
ass total falsch man könnte die viel
leichter ist und ja das klappt dann habe
ich auch noch so ein paar orangen
gekauft die ich sehr gerne esse und wir
haben auch noch chicken wings dann gibt
es auch was lustiges zu also im großen
und ganzen geht einfach um lebensmittel
die wir total falsch essen sein messer
ist echt brutal eingepackt ich habe mir
gerade ein neues messer zu gelebt ich
würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal mit
der ananas an ich bin extrem gespannt ob
das klappt ich zeige euch hier mal
kurzen videoausschnitt den ich gesehen
habe
es geht darum die ananas zu öffnen
und dann einfach hier diese stücke
rauszuziehen die man ganz entspannt
essen kann erst mal schneiden wir dianas
genau hier zwischen auf also komplett
halt darum das war gar nicht mal so
leicht
so nach zehn jahren bin ich dann auch
mal fertig und jetzt hoffe ich dass wir
die auch kriegen ja das geht ganz gut
zack so sieht's aus jetzt bin ich
wirklich mal gespannt ob das bei mir
auch klappt sowie in den videos die ich
gesehen habe weil meistens ist das sagen
genau nicht der fall
am besten drückt man jetzt schon ein
bisschen drauf hier und optimal wäre es
jetzt wenn man einfach die stücke raus
nehmen kann und das klappt sogar leute
jetzt haben wir ein stück google wir
haben ja praktisch genauso ein muster
also also eigentlich so vorgefertigte
stücke und die kann man jetzt einfach
rausziehen und so sieht das schon aus im
besten fall kann man halt einfach stück
für stück rausziehen bist die ganze
ananas weg ich bin jetzt auch überrascht
dass es so perfekt geklappt hat bei mir
ob das immer so ist weiß ich nicht aber
es funktioniert auf jeden fall sollte
ich würde sagen bevor wir zu den chicken
wings kommen machen wir so einen kleinen
orangen liveact hin habe ich auch
gesehen der sieht so aus das habe ich
hatte da dachte ich okay das ist doch
jetzt fehlt oder
ob das wirklich so einfach geht mit zum
beispiel jetzt dieser orange weiß ich
nicht wir checken dass man ab ich würde
sagen wünscht mir glück ich nehm doch
diese orange sieht schöner aus wir
schneiden einmal oben also einmal
hiervon auf der anderen seite genauso
torri hat vergessen der kleinen kamera
aufzunehmen
auf jeden fall die das ganze jetzt so
aus wir haben oben und unten einfach ein
stück abgeschnitten und jetzt schneiden
wir noch hier oben rein bis zur mitte
hatte typ zumindest zur video gemacht
zack und wenn das jetzt wirklich so
einfach gehen sollte kann man das ganze
entspannt aufklappen also so ganz
funktioniert hat es nicht hier kann es
gerne auch noch mal suchen ich schneide
es einfach mal noch ein bisschen mehr ab
ja ok
[Musik]
da würde ich sagen dass sie doch schon
gar nicht mal so schlecht aus auf jeden
fall sieht das ganze jetzt so aus ich
würde sagen man kann ja noch ein
bisschen mit messer nachhelfen
wir haben jetzt hier ein stück orange
und anstatt die so lässt sich zu schälen
können wir jetzt einmal essen
[Musik]
um dann aber auch ehrlich zu sein
also natürlich bleiben ein paar reste
dran und ist oft extrem wie man sehen
kann trotzdem an sich eine coole sache
und guten appetit
[Musik]
so leute ich hab mir mal aus spaß oder
was heißt auch spaß auf jeden fall sind
das jetzt hier drei chicken wings die
wir brauchen zum testen oder und
auszuprobieren ob der hack funktioniert
habe ich das schaffe so keller
leute was herzlich willkommen zurück ich
weiß gerade in der uni also das bild
sich das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
anders aus was hätte ich sonst leider
nicht mehr geschafft in den chicken
wings die müssen ja auch 15 minuten im
ofen auf jeden fall haben wir hier jetzt
drei von dem sich schmecken schicken
bringst du echt gut was nervt ist dass
man die halt so in die hand nimmt und
dann so ist das ist ja noch alles rund
um das zu umgehen habe ich auch ein
video gesehen ich kann es euch mal kurz
einbilden nicht so finde eine porno war
hier ist das moorland wie gouda dann
tröstet seine weist wissen regieren
welches portal just dance and this one
is listed seiner ist ein pole da an sich
geht es halt einfach darum diese hört
jetzt ziemlich brutaler ist es auch
eigentlich hier sind ja zwei knochen
drin man bricht die und zieht die
einzelnen raus weil dann sind die knoten
haid logischerweise wird ob ich das
jetzt hinkriege weiß ich nicht wir
probieren es einfach mal erfüllt sich um
irgendwie ein bisschen eklig und das
fühlt sich total eklig afag alltag
[Musik]
naja also dem klar habe ich jetzt
zumindest rausgezogen
so also leute es ist wirklich eklig ich
habe das jetzt mal versucht und ich habe
es jetzt so geschafft die glauben und
raus ja meine hände sehen allerdings
ziemlich mitgenommen aus und ich würde
auch nicht empfehlen das kann aber auch
daran liegen dass die qualität von
diesem chicken wings die sind jetzt
nicht frischwaren tiefkühlprodukte dass
ich dadurch halte die konsistenz von
fleisch verändert und man es nicht so
gut abziehen kann eventuell es kann
klappen aber auf jeden fall nicht so gut
wie diesem gezeigten video hört dann
kommt es ganz schnell zum letzten heck
ich hab mir gedacht das schlimmste auch
noch mit rein weil 30 und ein bisschen
wenig das habe ich sogar vor 14 monaten
auf install umgesehen es ist allerdings
auch in diesen amerikanischen videos die
ich euch eben mal kurz eingeblendet habe
und zwar wie hier ein schneidebrett das
gibt's ja noch in größe und jedes jahr
so ein loch drin vielleicht wissen dass
auch die meisten von euch ich wusste es
allerdings nicht kommen dafür hat das
benutzt man muss irgendwo dranzuhängen
oder es zu tragen keine ahnung ich habe
ja noch die orange auch wenn die sich
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht so gut dafür
eignet wir machen das trotzdem mal hier
mit ich schneide jetzt einfach mal in
ein paar stücke stellen einfach vor wir
sind jetzt schon warten darauf noch
etwas anderes keine ahnung
und jetzt muss man nicht auf dem teller
befördert und dafür ist nicht dieses
loch geeignet dass man das genau
passiert wo man die dinger hinhaben will
und dann schiebt man die eindrücke durch
oder fällt überhaupt ja nichts daneben
zack und alles auf den teller ich wusste
wirklich nicht dass es dafür geeignet
ist
wenn ihr das wusste könnte es gerne in
die kommentare schreiben auf jeden fall
würde ich sagen das war's mit einem
video ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn ihr sagt alex auf jeden fall noch
mit weiteren partner von dann schaue ich
mal was ich noch so finde und probiere
es einfach mal vor allem dass mit der
arbeit fertig krass hat auch recht
selber geklappt und jacek mich auf
inselrat 30 alex v ich fliege mal
nämlich wo hinten er übermorgen und das
wird wirklich richtig lustig also checkt
das abbild mich sehr freuen dahinter
folgt und wir sehen uns überhaupt wieder
gibt es noch nicht wieder
haut rein